- Do you wanna be friends?
Friends?
I'm a liberal and I tried
to make 100 new friends
at a Trump rally in Tennessee.
But what I thought was just gonna be
like this goofy adventure-
- We were abducted by aliens.
- Really?
turned into something much darker
and it completely changed
how I view America.
(crowd chanting)
But let me back up.
I live in Los Angeles,
which is one of the most
liberal cities in the country.
I feel like in LA, some people are like,
"If you're a Trump supporter,
I don't wanna be friends with you."
Would you fall into that camp?
- Yes!
- [Sam] And when I try to make
100 new friends at UCLA,
it went pretty well.
I even made some lasting friendships,
(cheers)
but maybe it's easier 'cause I'm in LA.
What about America at large?
Where it feels like we're
more polarized than ever.
So, I wanted to try this experiment again
and see if liberals and Trump
supporters could be friends,
which is why I flew to Memphis, Tennessee
and bought a ticket to
attend a Trump rally,
AKA the American Freedom Tour.
And holy (bleep), these
tickets are expensive.
Oh. and Malik is coming with me,
but he seemed a bit nervous.
How are you feeling about
going to a Trump rally?
(crowd yelling)
- I'm not prepared for any of that.
- [Sam] I didn't feel prepared either.
So to give our adventure some purpose,
I created a quest list.
I wanted to meet a celebrity,
have a meal with a Trump supporter,
get a Trump supporter to
invite me into their home.
And since I'm entering Bible Belt,
I figured let's try to go
to church with someone.
With our quest mapped out,
I got ready to meet Malik
for a 6:00 AM flight.
We meet again. (laughs)
Where are you guys from?
- I'm from Thailand.
- I love Thailand!
We have landed in Memphis.
- [Woman] Mr Norman?
- Yep, that's me.
- [Woman] Hi how are you?
- 1000% going to have to do
a montage with this truck.
♪ Oh, the fast life ♪
♪ The fast living ♪
♪ Fast living ♪
♪ They see the ambition ♪
♪ They know I'm past driven ♪
♪ Skrrt! ♪
♪ Look we are not the same ♪
♪ This is not a game ♪
♪ Not a game ♪
♪ I be swerving ♪
- Truck.
As I adjusted to this massive truck
and the ridiculously
warm weather of Memphis,
I was getting more and more stressed.
The more I thought about what I had to do.
So to calm my nerves, I
called my ex-girlfriend.
- Hello.
- Hey.
- Like, I don't have any
clue what I'm doing here.
- You should probably walk
around Memphis today to get a
feeling for the city.
It's like, you haven't talked to anybody.
You don't actually know
what the people are like.
You've never been to this place.
Get like culturally aware?
- [Sam] Honestly, great advice.
Quick question.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Do you think LA or
Memphis is friendlier?
- Oh, Memphis for sure.
- [Sam] Why?
- Oh, it's just friendlier
people than Los Angeles.
- [Sam] Do you wanna be friends?
- No.
- I've been to Gold.
- I feel like the people in LA
are assholes, so probably Memphis.
- I'm from LA.
- LA, cause you can smoke more kush there.
- Yo, you're drunk. Quit.
Memphis sucks.
I've lived here all my life.
- Y'all should come to The Bluff tonight.
- [Sam] What's, what's
happening at The Bluff?
- You've never been to The
Bluff on a Thursday night?
- This is my first time in Memphis,
of course I've never been.
- I'm sorry, I'm-
- Ask me another question.
- I was feeling a pretty friendly energy.
So I told people what the
heck I was doing in Memphis.
I, we have this show
called 100 New Friends.
- Okay.
- We were at UCLA.
We like brought 100 people together.
- Do you want to be friends?
- Friends! Friendship.
(cheering)
So, now we're trying to do the same thing,
but, like I'm kind of liberal
and I'm doing it at a Trump rally.
- Then, you are not in
the right city my friend.
- I love Trump.
He's just the first president we've had
that's actually spoke his mind in a while.
- Do you think like, it
would be hard for you
to be friends with a liberal?
- Absolutely not, no.
I feel like a lot of people are too
close-minded on that topic.
They'll kill an entire relationship
over a political interest.
- Liberals are more like 100%
like, more against Trump supporters.
(crowd shouting)
- Are you Trump or Biden?
- I'm a liberal.
- We can be friends though.
It's just an opinion.
- It's a matter of being-
- You know Trump's coming
to Memphis tomorrow?
- I'm going.
- Oh okay, oh!
Then you'll see me there.
- Probably won't come.
- You wanna come?
- Yeah, I mean. Yeah.
- Are you supporting Trump or Biden?
- Oh, Trump.
- You going to go to the rally?
- No.
- Hell yes.
- I'm gonna be there.
- Oh God.
I mean, is this what
the interview is about?
- I feel like Trump's a
genuinely good human being.
- Do you think he's sexist?
- [Trump] Grab 'em by the (bleep).
- Trump? Yeah.
- And that's what we've needed.
We needed somebody who's
gonna speak their mind.
- You need to go to some other people.
- But there was a silver
lining to our night out.
You wanna be friends?
- No.
- No?
- We got too many friends.
- [Announcer] Giving the match!
Boom! And Lawler with a right hand!
- [Announcer] Jerry, The King, Lawler!
- [Sam] It was pretty
cool that we met famed
WWE announcer, Jerry Lawler.
But I still couldn't shake the feeling
that I was out of my depth.
- Do you think LA or
Memphis is more friendly?
- Probably LA because people get shot
in Memphis all the time.
- We were down here last weekend
and three people got shot.
- Why?
- Crime rate's high.
It's Memphis.
- This place is the most
unsafe city in the nation.
- Just be careful-
I'm about to get a taxi.
- Do you have a bulletproof vest?
- I don't, I don't.
I feel like the resounding
advice from this trip has been,
- Don't go to Memphis.
- Why would you say Memphis is not good?
- Crime.
Memphis nowadays, it's number one.
- New study finds Memphis
is the most dangerous
city in the country.
This report comes as the Bluff City
is on pace to surpass a
record number of homicides.
(suspenseful music)
- [Sam] In an effort to get some thoughts
from the other side of the aisle,
I decided to follow some sage wisdom
I got the night before.
- Go to Rhodes Campus.
They're not Trump
anywhere near that school.
- I'd never heard of Rhodes before,
but they said it really puts
the liberal in liberal arts.
Campus is beautiful, but
there is no one here.
Hey, excuse me.
Do you guys wanna be friends?
- I'm cool with you.
- Sure, What's your name?
- Ricky.
- Isaac.
- Robin.
- Julia.
- Harrison.
How did you guys all meet each other?
- Orientation.
- Do you go here?
- No, I go to UCLA actually.
Turns out Ricky was an incoming freshman.
Super nice guy.
Philosophy major, liked
to ponder about the world.
And I had just stumbled upon orientation.
- [Man] Ready to meet the
challenge of college life.
- I've met a lot of people
from, like, both extremes
and, uh,
- Yeah.
- at the end of the day, I mean,
that's not really what it comes down to.
It comes down to, like,
who they actually are.
I just don't get into politics.
- It's not exactly someone's house,
but we kinda got invited to dinner.
I would call it, having
a meal with a Memphisian.
Mission accomplished.
We might not be able
to get like 100 people.
We're learning a lot about Memphis.
Excuse me.
Do you guys wanna be friends?
- [Woman] Yes!
- Sick!
- My name's Sam.
Beatrix, nice to meet you.
Sage, nice to meet to you.
This is Malik. Are you guys friends?
- No.
- Yeah?
- Oh.
(laughs)
- [Sam] Beatrix!
- We'll be friends after Sage graduates.
- Yeah.
- [Sam] Okay.
- [Narrator] A few moments later.
I don't really talk to Trump supporters.
And so I'm, there's a
rally here on Saturday.
- A word of advice.
I say tread lightly.
Not because these people
are like, super dangerous
or like, anything like that.
I think the people that
you are going to meet
believe what they believe for a reason.
Before you can have a conversation,
you have to have an element
of respect and understanding.
- Do you think you could be
friends with a Trump supporter?
- Probably have friends that
are Trump supporters right now.
But I also see like holding
the beliefs of hatred is
negative, negatively affecting the person
that holds those beliefs.
The Southern experience is not a monolith.
Like, you are probably not going
to find a lot of Trump
supporters in this area at all.
- Yeah.
We went down to Beale Street yesterday
- (chuckles) Yep.
and it was like 50/50.
- Uh, Trump.
- I'm liberal.
- I love Trump.
- Beale Street is probably not
super representative of Memphis.
You might find like,
people don't exactly vibe
with someone from LA
coming out with like fancy tech equipment
to like, talk about things.
- Yeah.
- I mean like, what are,
what are you doing on Saturday?
- I mean,
I'm doing Juneteenth things
and I'm not gonna invite
a white guy from LA.
Like, think about it for
like two and a half seconds
and it will make so much sense.
- [Announcer] Match, boom!
(calm music)
- Right now we're at the hotel where
Martin Luther king was assassinated.
- We must also realize that the
problems of racial injustice
and economic injustice cannot
be solved without a radical
redistribution of political
and economic power.
- What was your name?
- Murray.
- Murray. Sam.
- And they are the very people
telling the black man that he
ought to lift himself
by his own bootstraps.
- As you see with the people around here,
economics is a problem.
- Mm.
And I mean, people are just people,
which is why I just don't really
think that politics is ever
gonna work the way it's set up.
'Cause we just elect these
people to represent us.
But you can't represent everyone.
- How you feeling like emotionally?
Like, you okay?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
(upbeat music)
- Do you wanna be friends?
- No.
- No? Not even a little bit?
- I'm sorry, what?
- What?
(laughs)
- Nice to meet you guys.
Do you wanna be friends?
- Nah.
- Should we got another drink?
We should get another drink.
Let's get another drink.
- Are you with CNN?
- Do I look like I'm with CNN?
- Do you just do this to
meet women, older women?
- Oh, do you want me to meet you?
I like the horses.
(horse neighs)
- Thank you.
- Are you just vibin' out here?
- Yeah, I'm just chillin'.
- What's your name?
- Derek!
Hey man. Y'all be careful down here, okay?
- Love Derek, Derek's sick.
What do you think about, I guess like,
politics in friendship?
- If someone's conservative
in their politics,
that doesn't define who they are.
It probably more speaks to
their background, and you know,
ways they were raised.
- So you bury people in Arlington?
- Sailors, sailors.
We bury the sailors.
- You bury the sailors in
Arlington. Is it spooky?
- You get numb to it all.
- Like, like, like the dead-
- No it's, it's, it's,
- It's an honorable job.
- I saw your Bass Pro hat.
I just bought this one today.
Do you wanna be friends?
But we're Bass brothers.
Sailors.
How's your experience been?
- I'm just having a chill night.
- Malik, always chill.
And then Sam.
(party upbeat music)
(people cheering)
(suspenseful music)
I woke up day three, nervous.
It is almost seven
and we are going
to the Trump rally right now.
♪ I'm startin' south ♪
♪ Up to Tennessee ♪
♪ New lights, new sounds ♪
♪ It's everything I need ♪
♪ But I can't take no more ♪
- [Malik] 2024.
- [Sam] Who the (bleep) is Brandon?
- [Woman] As you can hear
the chants from the crowd.
- [Audience] Let's go Brandon!
- [Woman] Let's go Brandon.
- I feel uncomfortable.
- You don't know what's gonna go down.
♪ Who knew I would make it this far ♪
♪ They headed they never believe me ♪
♪ Never believe me ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ I would never turn the ball
I know I make it look easy ♪
- [Presenter] Welcome to
the American Freedom Tour.
We always like to set the tone right
by starting out by honoring
God and honoring the country.
- [Together] To the flag of
the United States of America.
- [Sam] And then there seemed
to be a call for friendship.
- [Presenter] Look
around. Meet new people.
Introduce yourself to new people.
- [Sam] I got a bit inspired.
So I took the pastor's
advice and decided to
say hi to a few Trump supporters
around the convention center.
Do you think Trump supporters or
Biden supporters are more friendly?
- Trump.
- Trump. Why?
- They just are.
- Trump supporters.
- That's a no brainer.
- What do you think?
- Trump supporters.
- We're American people.
God fearing individuals that just love and
support all aspects of the country.
- Trump supporters.
Because they love family
and they love God.
I'm from Mexico, but I
live in Canada since 2005.
- Why are you invested in Trump?
- I highly respect President Trump.
- Have you heard some of the quotes
that he's said about Mexico?
- They're bringing drugs,
they're bringing crime,
they're rapists.
- Does that make you feel any way?
- Not at all.
I'm Mexican and I live on
the border and I think what
he said about Mexico in
2016, I think it's true.
- Gas prices was a lot better.
Do you think that's like the main reason
that you support him?
- Biden don't know what he's doing.
- Why do you think that is?
- Everything's going up, inflation.
- Do you feel like, at home
in like the Trump community?
- Oh, I feel definitely feel at home.
- Are you from Memphis?
- Yes. I'm from Memphis.
It's tough, crime is very high and
a lot of people are outta work
and don't wanna work and
out looking for things to do
that's not, that's not good.
- Do you think you could
be friends with a liberal?
- Possible. I try to be
friendly to everybody.
- Absolutely. I got
- Yeah.
a lot of friends that are liberals.
- I got a lot of family that are liberals.
- Is that difficult at
all or is it pretty easy?
- It's very difficult.
Yeah. I'm just trying to talk.
- Yeah.
- And they just get upset.
- Do you have any friends currently that
are not family that are liberal?
- No, this is Tennessee.
- I actually wrote a book.
I don't call 'em Democrats.
I call 'em Dum-o-crats.
- I would actually say I'm
a liberal from LA actually.
What are your thoughts on LA?
- [Pastor] Turning to 2000 mules?
You know, this was a,
a tricky topic because,
- [Sam] Do you think you could
be friends with a liberal?
- Yeah.
- Do you think like, liberals would do
the same for you or no?
- No.
- Why not?
- Because they judge you on
before they get to know you.
- Two are detractors.
(bleep) you.
(echoed chatter)
(cussing)
(screaming)
- Oh, I can be friends
with anybody, but just
don't try to put your
stupid beliefs on me,
and I'm not gonna put my,
if you think my beliefs are stupid on you.
- Like, what do you
think the best way is to
like, unify the nation?
- Bring God back. Stop trying
to take it outta schools.
Stop persecuting your churches.
- I don't think America's that divided.
Reality is I would say the
majority, average American,
we probably disagree on
maybe four or five topics
and that's it.
- I would actually consider
myself like fairly liberal.
I'm from I'm from Los Angeles, like.
- Born in Santa Monica.
- I live in Santa Monica.
- Let me get a hug.
- I like that.
- Bill.
- Bill. Sam.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Firm handshakes!
I felt the ice break,
like this was real flowing conversation.
They knew I was a liberal,
but we're still down to just chat.
And we talked about a bunch of things,
but eventually we went down a
slightly different rabbit hole.
Have you done psychedelics before?
- Yeah.
- What are your experiences like?
- Well, $5 you can figure out
the meaning of life out
in the middle of desert,
seeing UFOs flying around
Edwards Air Force Base.
(laughs)
One thing-
- Do you believe in aliens?
- Yeah.
Uh, I believe in a superior being.
I don't think everything's
designed to keep us questioning,
but all we gotta do is have
faith in the Lord above and
love one another.
- Do you wanna be friends?
- Sure.
- Of course.
- Yeah.
- Sure. Why not?
- Oh, I don't care.
(Sam laughs)
- On what? Social media?
- Right now.
Sam. My name is Sam. What's your name?
- I'm Terry. Okay.
I got what you mean.
- Terry. (chuckles)
- I do too.
- On the bus by the way.
- You do?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I, can I have a tour of the bus?
- Go open the door and
walk in. I don't care.
- That was nice.
- I can't believe he
just gave me the keys.
♪ You ain't 'bout that fast life ♪
- [Sam] Trump was scheduled
to come out pretty soon,
and there was a ton of
anticipation inside,
but I wanted to chat to a few more people
before he took the stage.
I heard some commotion
outside and I saw a film crew
I thought I recognized.
They were wrapping up some interviews,
so, I went over to say hello.
Hello? How's it going?
Can I talk to you?
- No, not right now I'm,
I'm on a break, but.
- Okay. How long are you on a break for?
- For a little while.
- But your whole thing is
chatting to other people.
- Yeah, that that's, that's,
that's my thing, yeah.
- What happened on January 6th?
What do you think what happened there?
- I don't really know what
happened on January 6th.
- Then what's the difference?
- I am not the Commander
in Chief in charge of
the United States of America.
- Doesn't matter.
- Well, I think that's a,
I think that's an important detail.
But, uh, you don't want
to talk to other people.
- I'm sorry, but thank
you so much. Thank you.
- Alright, well, yeah,
have a good one. Later.
Jordan wouldn't talk to me,
but maybe one of the Trump supporters that
he was just talking to
would be down to chat.
- I'm pretty sure that's a
guy named Jordan Klepper.
Basically what he does is he
just clowns on Trump people.
- We get so demonized as
Republicans if we say anything,
they're like, "Oh, that's a conspiracy.
You're crazy."
- Do you wanna be friends?
- Sure.
- Okay, cool.
But you know what else I
believe? I'm also a Christian.
There's a lot of biblical
prophecy right now.
Like, being fulfilled.
- [Sam] Mm.
- I think Jesus is coming
back soon for sure.
- How soon?
- Think it could be this year.
- Yeah.
- For real.
Have you heard all the stuff
about aliens here lately?
- I was talking to a guy
excited about aliens.
- Like everybody's talking about UFOs.
You know what I think they're gonna say?
I think all the Christians,
we are just gonna disappear.
And I think they're gonna say that
we were abducted by aliens.
- Are you excited for that?
- I am very excited for it.
- Do you go to church?
- In my heart. I do.
- Are you going tomorrow?
- Yes.
- One of my goals was to like
go to church before I leave.
- I could find somewhere for you to go.
I go to women's class, but I could find.
- Can I come with you?
- Yes!
- Okay. A bunch of kindness yet again,
and I was feeling a little bit confident.
Maybe I had caught my buddy Jordan,
the only liberal at this
Trump rally at a bad moment.
So I want to go say hi to
see if we could be friends.
Do you wanna be friends?
- I'm so sorry. But we're so busy.
- We do want to be friends,
but he's working right now
so we can't do interviews.
- My job is to talk to
people. That's why I'm here.
- Yeah.
- Creating content for
the show that we work on.
- Yeah.
- If that's your job, that's great.
But my job is not to
talk to you about that.
My job is to talk to other people.
- He kind of represents
what I think I like,
am trying to not do.
Literally like, people here
have never heard of him
because he exists within
the liberal echo chamber.
I don't know if it changes minds.
It just like cements the,
- Your tribe or whatever. It
feels like the politicians
and as usual, people in charge
that are controlling everything
are taking advantage of
the people who have good intentions and
have been kind people.
Everyone I've talked to has been cool.
You can still find the
views absolutely disgusting,
and I do see some of them that way.
Politics is just one aspect of a person.
You know, there's a lot more to 'em.
- Maybe some of them are
confused, but they're,
they, they can still be kind.
There, there are people on the top that
are manipulating everyone below.
(psychedelic music)
I stepped back into the convention
center and the fervor of
the crowd was increasing.
Everyone was getting more and more excited
that Trump was about to take the stage.
And so on my way back in,
I ran into a few new friends.
How this looks. Ay!
Then I ran into Craig and
the conversation weirdly
turned to Burning Man.
- Do you want to go?
- No, of course not.
- Why not?
- It's a miserable, terrible place.
- Really?
- You are building community
from the ground up.
Isn't that exciting?
- You are using all the buzz words.
Oh, you're building community.
- But isn't that what we're doing here?
Like, we're building community.
You're talking to people like,
like this is a community
right here, right?
- I know what you're saying, but you know.
- Wait, why the eye
roll? Why the eye roll?
I'm, I'm probably not
using the same, like,
like, vocab that maybe
like, is more familiar,
but I feel like we're talking
about the same thing, right?
What rubs you wrong about what I'm saying?
- It doesn't rub me wrong.
- But you rolled your eyes.
- Anytime someone uses that word.
- Community?
- Yeah.
- You know, it's
you're trying to adopt significance.
- Isn't that what we're all trying to do?
(audience cheers)
(intense music builds up)
(upbeat music builds)
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
- [Trump] Thousands of proud,
hardworking American patriots
who believe in faith and famil-
- Oh, there's Buddy.
(bus beeps)
See you, Buddy!
Hey, do you wanna be friends?
- Huh?
- Do you wanna be friends?
- What?
- Do you want to be friends?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. My name's Sam.
- Hi.
- Helen, what did you
think of Trump's speech?
- Oh, I loved him.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
Yeah, I'm actually, I would actually
consider myself a liberal, of
uh, would you,
(Helen mumbles)
- Go ahead, talk to
her. I, I need to get a,
- Would you be friends with a liberal?
- Nuh-uh.
- Why not?
- 'Cause.
(suspenseful music)
(car doors closing and opening)
- [Sam] Hey, Holly.
How's your Sunday?
- You can come to our women's class.
- Okay.
Thank you so much for inviting me
over here.
- Oh, yeah.
- Hello!
- [Woman] Hi!
- I'm Sam, how's it going?
- I got some breakfast burritos,
and
- Oh my god, amazing.
Oh, thank you. Appreciate it.
- This is Samuel.
- Hello.
- One of Holly's friends.
- And now we're all new friends.
- So let's pray.
Our Lord Jesus. We just thank
you so much for this day.
And for this gathering of people, God,
we ask that you would be glorified,
that all that we hear and say,
God would just draw us closer to you.
Lord, help us to love you and
love those around us more.
Hear my prayer. Thank you. Amen.
- [Together] Amen.
- So in doing so, Solomon
said, "Okay, sure".
And then he married 700 (laughs)
- Just relax. I know I heard you laughing.
- Yeah. We, we probably have to
head out to catch our flight.
- Yes.
- But thank you so much
for like inviting you,
us into this world.
- [Woman] Can I take
a selfie really quick?
- Yes, of course. (laughs)
Thank you for inviting me.
- [Women] Yeah!
- Yah!
They're a fun group of people.
- [Malik] I like that.
- Yeah.
- That was nice.
- It was super wholesome.
- One time that people
were just all happy.
- Let's head out.
As Malik and I headed to the airport,
I was reflecting on this whole trip
and this whole idea of friendship.
Malik and I met randomly
at UCLA a few months ago,
all because I asked him,
"Hey, do you guys wanna be friends?"
He could've said no, and so
much would've been different.
But because he said yes,
it led to us traveling across the country
and doing something
that we'll both remember
for the rest of our lives.
This friendship, like most
of the best things in life
started out with a small
step, a tiny interaction.
A question.
Now, it's led to this deep friendship.
On this journey,
we connected with so many people
that didn't share our politics at all.
And it left me wondering if
this divide, Trump versus Biden,
red versus blue, Democrat
versus Republican.
It's way of thinking that
doesn't serve anyone.
- The prodigal son has
come from Tennessee.
- Hello, father. Hello, mother.
So mom, I have a gift for you.
- I don't want it.
- Oh yeah.
- Let's see it on.
- I- no.
- No! No! No!
- Put it on! Put it on!
- It can go next to my other
like truck memorabilia.
Stop!
Toilet paper.
- [Man] She could put that
- Nice.
- next to the toilet paper.
- Stress ball.
- (laughs) That is.
Are you sure, are you sure
you don't want to keep it?
And wear it?
- Put it there.
- Okay. Wow.